let's go next to um
oh i don't know uh there's a lot of lot
of people a lot of interesting folks
waiting today why don't we go to
ruminate in kentucky is ruminate your
first or last name it is just my stage
name okay
david man i appreciate you taking the
call and you can you hear me well i can
hear you beautifully
perfect
so i'm a big fan of the show i was
introduced to you during the pandemic
okay and uh you and like brian tyler
cohen and a bunch of others you helped
get me through it so i appreciate you
know all that you do
i do have a specific question about
rhetoric moderating rhetoric so
you know friends of yours like destiny
who i'm also a fan of and even your new
correspondent uh luke beasley who did a
great job in texas um
they are fans of or they seem to be
proponents of
moderating rhetoric that leftists even
progressive leftists in terms of their
public outreach
should moderate their rhetoric
even though the gop seems to be
increasingly radical increasingly
aggressive
um and there's like this this um dispute
in the leftist community should we be
more aggressive should we try to appeal
more across the aisle and i'm curious
what you think about it well let me ask
what do you what why do you say that our
correspondent luke seems to favor
moderating rhetoric what gave you that
impression
he did uh a discussion with vosh or
vaush yesterday it was a really good
conversation oh luke beasley did
yeah yep how did they get in touch
that's fascinating i didn't know they
talked to each other i mean your name
carries weight man he's he's a d-pack
correspondent that's like that's
political royalty oh i'm gonna have to
watch that okay and so he said he was a
fan of moderating rhetoric
yeah because i mean i'm sure you're
familiar enough with bosh know that you
know which i'm a fan of his as well but
he definitely takes a more aggressive
route with respect to rhetoric he thinks
that the republican party as an
institution its leadership is evil
they're morally wicked and so he feels
that there should be
a greater condemnation of the gop by
leftists by democrats by progressive by
just bog standard liberals yep and
luke's position was broadly like hey man
i think that that's going to scare
people away
and i see both sides of it but i also
feel that this is the loop is aired more
closely on the side of moderate rhetoric
is a moderate person
and yet it doesn't seem to be doing him
any favors with independence and
centrists and whatnot so that's why i
wanted your take on i mean you you in
your videos you are very candid that the
republican party and the democratic
party
though flawed are not comparable the
democrat republicans are infinitely
worse as as a institution yeah do you
think that leftists
should be more emphatic about that like
no that this this notion of a bipartisan
you know future and that we need a
strong republican party like speaker
pelosi says that that's just crap and
we've got to get more radical in our
rhetoric so here's my view i don't think
that it should be one thing or the other
for contrived reasons of optics or
strategy i think that we should just be
really clear about calling things as i
see them so i can't speak for anybody
else's perspective my perspective is i'm
not going to artificially use milder or
more extreme rhetoric
just for the reason of how it will look
i'm going to describe things in the way
that i think they are and with the
language that i think is most
appropriate and when i'm talking about
radical repugnant lunatic trumpists
that's right what i'll call them i won't
say anything that's moderate more
moderate or more extreme than than what
i see them as being i'm open to other
people saying no the strategy should be
to use either more moderate or radical
rhetoric for this reason or for that
reason my approach and people can tell
me it doesn't work or it's wrong is i i
just call things and describe things as
they are with the language that feels
accurate
right fair enough and then one last
thing i just want to say i think that
you are
you're probably your standout quality on
your shows you are a superb interviewer
so i was going back and watching your
interviews with tim poole and michael
knowles and sam harris in that recent
one trigonometry um i guess my last
question is do you
do right wingers or more centrist
figures like sam harris isn't a right
winger but he is certainly more centrist
i think sure than many others do they
avoid
uh interviews with you or or like do you
reach out to people often to have those
sorts of incisive q's and a's and do
they do they take you up on the offer
it's a mix we reach out to tons of
people all the time and there's no rule
you know sam harris has previously
accepted requests from us but for a year
and a half i've been trying to get him
back on and he is not accepted so i i
there's no hard and fast rule but i'm
obviously open to talking to all sorts
of people
yeah well i appreciate it david thanks
and keep doing what you're doing man
thank you so much appreciate the call
i'm gonna have to check out that vaush
and luke beasley appearance that sounds
pretty interesting
one of our sponsors is emmy
hands down some of the best ramen
noodles i've had just like any instant
ramen you pop emmy into the microwave or
on the stovetop for a few minutes and
it's ready to go but what makes imme
different is that it is packed with 21
grams of protein lower in sodium 100
plant-based with 18 grams of fiber for
digestive health and it tastes
excellent
so many of the other ramens are bland
simple artificial imi uses high quality
ingredients and recipes you get a zing
of flavor i've never had with any
instant ramen imi comes in amazing
flavors like spicy beef tom yum shrimp
and black garlic chicken if you try emmy
and don't love it
you get your money back you'll get five
dollars off when you go to emmyeats.com
pacman and use the code pacman at
checkout the link is down below